hey guys welcome back to spectrum we
would like to thank the Tri guys for
being such awesome guests in this
episode and we would like to remind you
that if you want to participate by
either suggesting prompts for future
episodes or predicting what the cast
answers will be in the video you can
follow us on Instagram and get involved
that way so check us out and enjoy the
episode views can't be all that matters
because if that was the case then the
greatest artists of our generation would
be vine compilations which are great
there don't
I'm keepers burger I'm Ned Fullmer I'm
Zach Kornfeld I'm Eugene Lee gang and I
am a tri guy I always look forward to
finding out things that I don't already
know
not looking forward to answering
personal questions but really who is I
just hope that this is a chance for you
to get to know us more deeply and
intimately than ever before I look
forward to creating the most insane
chaotic Jubilee spectrum video in the
history of this channel that's pretty
that's pretty great pretty [ __ ]
stupid yeah I guess says the odd man out
like I'll try anything once
no I'm going back here whoo you can't be
in the middle can't be there oh well I
don't want to murder anybody
well you've never tried murdering
someone I'm just oh so I tried emergen I
can try to murder someone but not
actually tell them we always associate
trying with positivity I mean I guess I
didn't think about murdering someone as
being part of the net foamer is a
murderer no I'm not a strong murder in
the try guys I'm the cute one
I'm the neurotic Jewish one we gotta
talk to this hands a lot uses a lot of
pop-culture references when they're not
necessary and pushes probably more of
our absurdist content well a lot of
semantics there yeah yeah all right
what are you doing you know you're right
I think here that movie is so
objectively abysmal that it transcends
to a new realm of being as a modern
cinematic masterpiece so I'm standing
here to say that I stand for cats
is Pizza an open-faced sandwich is a
taco a sandwich if you think a hotdog as
a sandwich you are wrong and you should
unsubscribe from this channel aliens the
universe is vast and infinite and
ever-expanding there's got to be life
somewhere and look at the lobster what a
creature the lobster is how can this
earth have both humans and lobsters how
do you know that we're not aliens
I don't yeah I watched my prom date hook
up with someone else yes aim yeah it
hurt it's still it still hurts my prom
date for one of mine was dating someone
else at the time and but the prom is
what changed it and got us to start
dating so I'm sorry though we didn't
make out we just fell in love a little
bit of poop you've probably eaten before
I don't care much for brownies but it's
the tastiest one in the world Eugene
don't you want to say that you happen
like I don't hear I'm like so I don't
care we're just talking about Eden I'm
Way over here
I'm the tri guy known for his greatest
hits of not being white or straight I'm
also probably best known for being the
one with the darkest opinions and the
least optimistic view on life everything
is going slowly to [ __ ]
that's tough you know it changes all the
time you guys felt us move this way and
didn't want to see my [ __ ] I think
that our strength is that there is not a
standout we are truly an ensemble and
we're all great in different ways and
that's hopefully what makes us fun to
watch I don't know I think Keith's the
best try guy okay we all have like fans
that feel that maybe they like me the
most so they like fact the most so like
NAT or Eugene the most but our dynamic
speaks to lots of people in that way but
they still come back for the show more
than they come back for our individual
products gotta be honest oh it feels
really cool over here you should give it
a shot try some proper name you should
give it a shot it feels good to think
that maybe you are like I am the best
try guy oh no I just never crossed my
mind I think it were yeah we're just an
ensemble
[Music]
mm I'll take this one I mean no but
right it's like I don't miss it
but there were so many awesome people
that work there they really helped to
build that video department and it was a
really magical time it was before
Facebook even had video and we were like
experimenting and it was really cool and
it felt like you were on the ground
floor of something exciting for a whole
cultural revolution of how content
existed but I'm Way happier now but the
question was do you miss Buzzbee I mean
I don't miss BuzzFeed at all right sure
those early days were great but now
we're in the early days of building
something new and exciting with our
awesome creative people on our own staff
for ourselves that's way better yeah
yeah it is way better just a sentimental
boy sometimes me think about we've met
there you know so that's that's you know
I got to acknowledge it I mean I don't
miss middle school but like yeah there
are people that I liked there I observe
I miss to me like would you like to go
back okay no I'm the goofy one I do a
lot of silly fast food videos a lot of
absurd impromptu singing and I probably
try to avoid responsibility the most
keep is worried about his health and I
guess I should be worried about his
health
Oh somewhat you know it's a lot of
eating really poor quality meats and it
creates a lot of stomach stretching
years ago I'd be here but today I think
maybe I'm over here because I know what
you do in your lifestyle now you're much
healthier in your lifestyle yeah once
those videos started becoming popular it
was about the same time I decided I
shouldn't be so unhealthy so you know I
showed up today with a green smoothie
and
working out two to three times a week
was in every day before and also when I
shoot those videos to try to work out a
lot the days before so my metabolism is
better and I think that you are so hyper
ly aware of what's going into your body
at other times maybe because of it that
maybe you know that garbage is making
you a better person maybe if you ate
like [ __ ] before I did eat terribly
before and honestly I think like eating
garbage every day is probably worse than
eating it all concentrated for one video
yeah you know maybe the videos have made
them a healthier person
[Music]
you should eat garbage - oh really
it is an achievement to have two videos
a week in your channel for almost two
years even if some of the videos aren't
as good as others that's right that's
kind of like saying you're proud of your
city kid when you're independent every
video is a triumph no I agree happy that
we have two videos a week I'm not proud
of every video mmm well I don't think
these guys care that much for the bark
slur
it's a short-lived series where i rated
people's dogs I made a video where I
watched every Dolan twins video that was
gonna be a big hit it wasn't I thought
it was a good idea rather than not
release videos in January when we went
on a Christmas vacation to release
compilation videos they were both very
average people saw right through it
audio I can look wherever I why I'm the
one that always talks about his wife and
his baby
I'm the quote/unquote responsible one
but really that can be quite
irresponsible
can't go to Disneyland without taking
about 40 photos yeah I'm not like Justin
Bieber no dude you're just like Justin
beings man you're wearing the same
sweatshirt color that he wears and that
song that's not that great yummy yummy
that what it's called is that about what
I think it's about yes I'm here because
I see growth well I mean we're internet
famous
I used to say we were famous because
you're famous to a huge demographic but
then there's other demographics that are
like completely locked out so sometimes
like kids will come up and then their
parents are like who's that who are you
and it's it's weird to deal with someone
who's like super excited and someone
who's almost being like condescending
because they haven't heard of you
like I go to an Ed Sheeran concert I get
recognized a lot
I go to an NFL game you know I can
usually coast by with the hat and a
Jersey and you know enjoy the game
it's impressive considering I'm the most
insecure too I'm saying somewhat
disagree because on the whole I know
that psychologically for every one
negative comment you read it's the power
of a thousand positive comments so to do
anything in the public eye you need to
learn to just shake it off and and not
take it to heart cuz yeah it's just
bogus I mean I do what you guys are
saying but it still affects me there was
an episode of tried DIY that we almost
took down because there was many
negative comments about our significant
others I don't talk about it but I
constantly get comments about my race
and my sexuality it sure and I've
constantly gotten write comments about
that in person before I was even an
entertainer
so as strong as I need to appear which i
think is a requirement as a
representative of that race and
sexuality I'm still like the sensitive
to a kid who got made fun of for it
I'm sensitive to it because I have to
make sure everything I do is empowering
and not making me look weak I guess in
reality I am probably over there I just
know that they should be over there this
is where I need to be yeah this is my
active choice of how I deal with it is
to Yammer supposed to be all the way
over there yeah so maybe your feet are
here and our hands are over there do you
wanna make a bridge together yeah let's
make a bridge Wow yeah come on we're
[Music]
I'm sorry I would understand any answer
in this prompt they matter because
they're pretty much a direct relation to
your earnings since we have a company
with other people that rely on that
company to be successful for their
income as well and it's exciting when a
video like starts getting views really
fast in that first day because you feel
accomplished because it means it's
resonating with people it's spreading
yeah put good in the world and it's
gotten that much farther the message to
spread that much further look if you
counts didn't matter at all we wouldn't
be here maybe what you wouldn't even be
watching this video because this company
wouldn't exist there are often times
where you do not accurately predict the
success of the video and sometimes
that's frustrating because there are
videos the work really really hard on
you think they're really awesome and
then they perform ok and then there
videos that you you know you sit down
you eat a table full of fast food and it
crushes you like well this isn't the
best message you can't be all that
matters because if that was the case
then the greatest artists of our
generation would be vine compilations
which are great they're dope you want to
hopefully find the middle ground how do
you make something that is great and
meaningful and deep and specific that
also can find a snitch and thrive and
grow yeah but if we were getting 10
times as many views but we thought all
of our content was very shallow and
Hollow and not enriching the world I
think we would feel pretty bad about
ourselves like we have videos that have
8 10 20 million views there's one video
I made that has one or two million views
and that's the video that I got talked
to about more than anything
so it's not not that direct
the try guys well it's not that simple
you know like letting someone join that
that implies that the show is just
talent based and it's not just talent
based it's it's directorial it's
produced it's really well thought out
it's based on a lot of statistics and
measuring over like six years I get I
could be on either somewhat you know
I've been joining to me is like there's
some you know random person here with
like a yellow hoodie like hey it's Karl
we've been doing it for so long I don't
think we're ever gonna we'd have to call
it something different like the new try
guy you can never say never like yes the
four of us no it's probably hard to
imagine that dynamic changing but I
think it's inevitable for our growth
that in the next 5-10 years yeah I think
it's going to benefit us to expand the
cast and allow people with different
perspectives and different backgrounds
to try things that will deepen and
enrich in our videos and allow us to
grow in different directions I'm kidding
we hang out on weekends we go on
vacations together but that can Keith
are the best friends yeah you guys
better better step it up well I mean Ned
obviously has a son Eugene is also like
normally got some gala he's going to so
he's harder to hang out with on a whim
and Zach and I are pretty not busy
outside one they were all my Guzman in
my wedding because yeah they're some of
the most important people in my life and
I've been forcefully told that for my
eventual wedding I'm gonna have to do
the same yep the nature of the show that
we do it like friendship is a result of
the experiments because you're doing all
these new things together you're very
vulnerable around one another in like
every context so doing that 200 times
for the same people the best friend boot
camp you could ever have we're actually
delusional we're
not friends but the experiences make us
think that were think it's made me a
better friend and I think it's made me
more open I was shaped by a lot of more
formative experiences with my background
that really pulled me from dark places
and I think that this has just been the
most successful friendship I've ever had
but it certainly hasn't I don't think
it's constructed the core of my
character it made you a happier person
yeah it's made me somewhat happier yeah
I think about I made you like babies a
little bit your baby it's made me like a
little bit more I agree it has made me a
better person I but I think there are
probably ways in which our work ethic to
this company has maybe made me a worse
person to some people in my life right
like as we have become more busy my time
with other friendships or relationships
is certainly dwindled a bit and I feel
bad about that sometimes I think we're
really lucky that we get to do so much
stuff I never would have otherwise done
yeah I think that's made me a better
person for sure yeah if you measure a
life and experiences this is the single
greatest thing that could have ever
happened to us and I'm just a much more
personal level it's it's made me more
confident and secure with who I am it's
made me happier it's allowed I think my
personality to to thrive and flourish
where before being on the internet I I
think I was a very insecure closed-off
person and somehow subjected myself to
strangers in the world made me a much
happier guy nice and I made three best
friends
[Applause]
and a dab callback don't forget that
don't have
yeah I'm deeply offended about the cats
one yeah that doesn't even seem the
movie I haven't saved me he can speak
what I'm sorry I know we want supposed
to see this house weekend we didn't look
cats is not a good movie it's a bad good
yeah if you know it's bad good and you
are very high